hello hello all right I believe we are
live um welcome welcome to everybody
going to go over some stories for
tomorrow's show take questions all of
that stuff I'm actually doing the stream
today not from my mobile phone but
instead through my actual HD webcam and
Blue Yeti mic so I think that that will
be better I believe anyway uh who knows
at this point it's anybody's guess uh
there's crazy breaking news so today on
the show we did this story about um how
parts of that blackmail dossier about
Donald Trump are are actually true true
so Trump wrote the entire thing off as
fake news at the beginning said it's all
fake nobody was briefed on it blah just
it's all completely fake right um then
we found out okay well no actually the
dossier does exist but Donald Trump
insists nobody was briefed about it and
the content is all fake news then we
found out oh no actually Trump and Obama
were briefed about it and the dossier
does exist but the content of it isn't
true and then now we know that actually
some of the content is true I don't know
if the urine fetish stuff in true is
true that hasn't been corroborated but
at least we know now that some of the
conversations that the dossier claims
took place uh took place and in the wake
of this just after we got done with
today's show I was reading a report
which says that in its daily
intelligence briefings with Donald Trump
the
NSA the NSA is so concerned over the
ties That increasingly are are clearly
real between Donald Trump and Russia
that they are hiding information about
that from Trump during their briefings
if you're Congress and you're being told
that intelligence is hiding information
from the president because it relates to
the president's relationship to Russia
it might be time to start a legitimate
investigation right uh I I think that
this this is sort of a sign that it's
time to start looking into that um so
we're going to be going into that story
in detail um on tomorrow's program and
this is just one report uh let's see if
I can even put the link I'm looking at
in the chat here um yes there it is I
think that that works um and there's
there's more of these coming up and I I
look forward to digging into this every
morning when I wake up I never know I
think I know what the show's going to be
um and then crazy stuff happened at 4:00
a.m. with Donald Trump on Twitter or
something and the entire show changes
and and you know we're basically are
back to the drawing board of the studio
um okay I want to mention number one
Super Chat is enabled last time I did a
stream I think it was four people used
Super Chat and you can use super chat to
make your comments visible sometimes the
stream uh the the chat just goes so
quickly uh that it's hard to even keep
up with it you can use Super Chat also
we'll be doing live shoutouts and thank
yous to anybody who signs up at
davidpakman.com membership during the
Stream last time we had a whole bunch of
people doing that um you can use the
coupon code I voted 17 to get a discount
and on that note um big shout out to
Corey Kennedy who I see um just signed
up for membership at David pacman.com
membership whether you play pay full
price or use the coupon code I voted 17
I don't care any new members during the
live stream uh live shout outs and thank
yous let's get to some of the other
stories we're going to be looking at
tomorrow the Donald Trump approval
rating
um is continuing to just fall off a
cliff Gallup does this daily tracking
poll they've been doing it for decades
obviously some people say well we can't
trust any polling because polling was
wrong during the election number one the
premise is false and number two the
conclusion is false number one the
premise being false the average of of
polling most polls had Hillary Clinton
winning the popular vote by somewhere
between two and four points Hillary
Clinton won the popular vote by nearly 3
million votes so number one the poll
weren't wrong uh yes within the margin
of error they they were wrong in some of
those key states where as a result of
77,000 votes Donald Trump won
electorally so the premise that we we
can't trust polls now because the
election polls were wrong is based on
the faulty notion that the election
polls were wrong also the daily Gallup
tracking poll um has been done in the
exact same way for decades and decades
it's a completely different thing than
then uh guessing based on a likely voter
model as to who that you're speaking to
is a likely voter or not Etc so it's a
totally different model in any case the
Gallup daily tracking poll remember this
is the one in which Donald Trump
achieved 50% disapproval in a record
eight days it took Ronald Reagan 727
days to get to 50% disapproval it took
Bush one over 1300 days anyway I gave
you the list on the January 30th show
after 8 Days Donald Trump hit 50%
disapproval according to the most recent
Gallup daily presidential approval
tracking poll Trump at 55% disapproval
55%
disapproval um and uh it it is it is
just genuinely not looking good for
Donald Trump as far as that goes and I
just finished an interview with madelin
G for her Channel um about this exact
issue issue um and I said that that
there clearly are some Republicans who
are starting to starting to say is this
someone that I want to be putting all of
my support behind is this even going to
be it for me and fundamentally I think
that's what's really at issue here um
with a lot of the Republicans that are
that are I mean every everybody's up for
real election in 2018 in the house um I
I think that that is a major major issue
for them saying I don't I know the guy
seems to be completely unbalanced but at
the same time if I'm too loudly against
Trump right now then it might hurt my
re-election chances if Donald Trump's
approval rating goes up and being
attached to Trump is a positive thing if
Trump's disapproval rating keeps going
up if Trump's approval rating keeps
going down the way we've seen happen
during the first few weeks of his
presidency I would assume that you're
going to see way way more um Republicans
more vocally opposed to Donald Trump
sleepy stew sending a Super Chat saying
will I interview sugata Mitra of
Newcastle England I have no idea who
that
is um but I I'll make a note of it um
and see who that is and uh after the
after the live stream I'll see if it's
uh somebody interesting to interview um
shout out to Anthony Mitchell Anthony
Mitchell who just became a David Pacman
show member using the coupon code I
voted 17 that gets you a 40% discount I
am not looking to stretch people
financially with membership which is our
number one funding source if the normal
rates are high for your budget use the
coupon code there's absolutely no
problem whatsoever I voted 17 is the
coupon code available at David
pacman.com
membership uh a couple of people saying
that my audio is out of sync so here's
the deal in order to stream stream with
my HD webcam and Blue Yeti microphone
which is just off camera right there uh
I have to use some kind of intermediate
software I'm using one called manyam and
it's possible this is the first time I'm
doing it it's possible that it is
creating some kind of audio video uh out
of sync issue um and unfortunately I I
don't have much control over that if
it's not good I'll check it out after
the stream is over if it's not good I
can go back to streaming from my uh
phone and uh you know there's pluses and
minuses the pluses being I think the
Blue Yeti mic sounds way better um the
the minus from being uh on this system
might be the delay so I apologize
apologize about that um okay we're also
going to be discussing on tomorrow's
show Donald Trump's plan to go to the
United Kingdom has absolutely and
completely imploded um there was this
initial plan where oh maybe Donald Trump
is going to address uh Parliament or
maybe he's not it's not clear is he
going to London is he going to go to
Birmingham instead and at this point
we've heard that to avoid embarrassment
it appears that the entire trip is going
to be rescheduled altogether um and it's
it's amazing that somebody used the
analogy of the boiling frog
um this is this is this sort of analogy
where if you put a frog in a cold pan
and you turn up the heat because the
heat will go up slowly the frog doesn't
notice that it's getting burned and the
way that it applies here is that because
crazier and crazier things are happening
under Donald Trump we're sort of getting
desensitized right so so he he ridiculed
and mocked this um uh reporter and it
was completely shocking and whatever but
then it fell into the background because
then he was doing the grabbing by the
video and 16 women or 12 women or
whatever number it was accused Donald
Trump of sexual assault so then the the
making fun of the disabled reporter sort
of fell backwards and the the three
weeks or however many weeks I guess it's
been yeah about three weeks since Donald
Trump took office it's been such
constant chaos and insanity and and
scandal after Scandal and embarrassment
after embarrassment um that I think
there's been a sort of
desensitization to the insanity of what
is going on here I mean what I started
with here was uh that there the NSA is
reportedly hiding information from Trump
during Intel briefings remember this is
the guy who supposedly needs to know
everything uh so that he can make
National Security decisions that that
keep people safe the NSA is troubled so
troubled by the Russia Trump links that
they're actually hiding that information
from Trump during the Intel briefings
this is a systemic National Security
crisis if fundamentally the NSA uh can't
trust Trump with the information they
have uh because of how it relates to
Trump himself that's a just a
fundamental national security issue and
I don't I don't know what the endgame is
um uh user alternative fact check has
sent a Super Chat uh saying the lack of
an Affordable Care Act replacement will
sync Trump well you may have noticed
that um there's been a lot less talk
about repealing Obamacare lately um and
we heard from Sean Spicer Trump's
hairbrain press secretary the other day
that Hey listen Obamacare is a big thing
um it's going to take a while could take
a year to come up with a replacement and
it it's really stunning to me the level
of incompetence that you must be
experiencing Trump campaigned on
repealing Obamacare for so long you
would think he would have a really
specific plan by the time he gets into
office for how to replace it so that you
can move on that quickly If You Believe
As Trump says that the Affordable Care
Act is such a disaster for
America um how would it be acceptable to
wait even a month before repealing it
and that's where we are right now almost
at a month and of course the Affordable
Care Act the same thing as Obamacare I
know some people in the chat um asking
about that a lot of Americans don't
realize that the Affordable Care Act is
the same as uh Obamacare and this is
part of the problem even Trump
supporters when you ask them do you like
keeping up to 26 year olds on their
parents insurance they mostly like it do
you like uh barring health insurance
companies from denying coverage based on
pre-existing conditions most of the
trumpists like it they just don't like
the mandates that are included which are
sort of the key point I mean without the
mandates you need to cover the cost of
of adding people to the risk pool with
premiums and so you can't mathematically
have without our for-profit system of
course you can't mathematically have all
the stuff the Trump supporters like if
you don't have some way of paying for it
so yeah I mean I think um the the all of
the comments that I'm seeing in the chat
about the Affordable Care Act really
really important uh in that they point
out uh very accurately that this is an
impass and indeed um this may become a
really really big problem for uh Donald
Trump shout out and thank you to Brian
Kelly Brian Kelly has used the coupon
code I voted 17 uh when signing up for
membership at David pacman.com
membership which I mentioned in the chat
thank you to Brian Kelly really
appreciate everybody who has signed up
uh oh and also uh membership's coming in
almost faster than I can read them Quinn
black Quinn thank you for signing up for
membership not using the I voted 17
coupon code choose choosing to um uh pay
full price okay someone suggesting that
I might be able to fix the audio sync
issue by adjusting the latency in manyam
I don't know how to do that so if
someone tells me how to do that I would
be glad to do it um but maybe you can uh
send me some specific information and
maybe that'll get the audio and video to
match up I know that that that can be
really really annoying um so I I
apologize about that um okay I had a
couple other things things that I wanted
to discuss here uh let me pull those up
and in the meantime uh questions
comad already about a little bit
of oh okay here's something else I'm
doing I the David Pacman show is many of
you know has been um going through
changes we did a fundraiser we're going
to be doing new stuff and in the Trump
era just everything sort of seems to
have uh uh exploded in terms of interest
and a lot of the issues that we're
talking about one thing I'm doing is to
to try to get a sense of what it is
people like but just as importantly
don't like about the show I've put
together a very short survey which is at
davidpakman.com
survey and whether it's now or later if
you were able to take that survey I
would really really appreciate it so
that we can get some information about
what people um like don't like about the
show there's a couple questions about
what platform you you most um and can't
imagine that this would take take you
more than 90 seconds at the most
pacman.com
survey um and take care of that Brody
Andrew Mulligan has sent a Super Chat uh
where he says
what does he say could Intel withheld
increase the risk of terrorism
absolutely if agencies like the NSA are
withholding information from the
president because they are concerned
about what might happen if they present
him with that information uh then
absolutely that that's a national
security risk fundamentally and it's an
absolute and utter disaster that that
needs to be dealt with so yeah like I
said it is no the current in
intelligence situation which includes
the NSA allegedly withholding info from
Trump at as well as Trump not reading
anything that's more than a few bullet
points and some maps on a single page as
we reported today that increases the
risk of the us being victimized by uh
terrorism Matt Foreman sending a Super
Chat saying David how do you feel about
General Flynn's conversation with Russia
thoughts yeah so the background on this
is um that we initially were told that
when National Security adviser former
General Michael Flynn former Lieutenant
General I believe Michael Flynn spoke to
the Russian assador they did not talk
about Russian sanctions he said it in
totally definitive terms didn't talk
about it and then it started to leak
that you know actually maybe they did
talk about it and of course Mike Pence
when asked about it uh said oh no they
absolutely didn't talk about it so
there's a lot of reporting that Pence is
furious with Michael Flynn that he's
been put in this situation um it's it's
yet again you know it's constant lying
from the Trump
Administration um uh it's it's
concerning and it also would be quite
frankly completely unethical for um the
National Security advisor the as yet
unconfirmed National Security adviser of
a president-elect who has not yet been
inaugurated to be talking about
sanctions with the
Russian
in
we've that
you
know
does
what
but there's
being
RIS
and be
just
mon
do we do extra show every
day just
forus
pre
from
St
okay many I can
change
[Music]
with
video about
do to
point
d
un and
we
B
I'm
get
being
what if
my
or
okay
what
that
okay let
me
what
um we are
Al
going
told
okay
it
it's how
this
way
to
really
f
can
right
are we
back I believe we are back uh I'm not
sure if that worked but I believe that
we are indeed back
um anybody can anybody let me know I
believe we're back okay um all right so
we're going to be talking about how to
fight fake news tomorrow I think that's
going to be a really really good story
story and um so just just some of the
stories we're going to be dealing with
tomorrow big thank you to James McDaniel
James McDaniel just went to David
pacman.com
membership created a mersh the coupon
code I voted
17 40% discount thank you to James
McDaniel and the the level of
TR has instantly
um I don't know what must have said over
the last few minutes but something
has and um yeah wow uh anyway I'm glad
to be back here some questions from the
chat if people it just went live and you
can check it out if you want uh whenever
I mean you could navigate away from the
chat you could check it out um when when
the live stream is done it's a it's a
followup about the entire Trump reading
thing and um we you know I'm not seeing
anything that suggests to me that Donald
Trump can read at more than a fourth or
fifth grade level and I'm seeing more
and more uh that suggests to me that
Donald Trump cannot actually on to
fourth or fifth grade level so check
that out um and I think that that uh is
a video that we do
really really well um there's the
suggestion from John Johnson that I do
some kind of video on capitalism versus
socialism I don't know if capitalism
versus socialism is the um right framing
for it but what I am increasingly
interested in is that I I I've been sort
of thinking about this a lot and there's
a few good articles about it most
Americans sort of like your average
American with a more or less
accurate understanding of of of society
and our economy most people are
democratic socialists to some degree
they just don't really realize it and uh
it's it's because Democratic socialism
is just sort of like a such an obvious
part of American society when you look
at areas of society where we are
socializing the cost through taxes that
it wouldn't even occur to them that we
might organize the economy in any other
way but they still hear Democratic
socialism and think that it's just
objectively an absolute and total
disaster so I think that that would be a
more interesting long form piece to do
something like you're probably a
Democratic Socialist no matter what it
is that you think or uh or or something
like that so I think that that's um
something that that I'd be interested in
doing a long form piece on I mentioned
last week we're also working with
segment producer Noah Ferguson on a long
for piece on Jerry mandering which I'm
going to be
um hopefully wrapping up in the next
couple of weeks and Publishing for you I
think that that would be a really really
uh good piece what's the latest with the
audio video sync can anybody let me know
it's hard for me to tell exactly whether
the lag is good or bad or not good I
don't know exactly how this is going um
but it's it's looking better on my end
um I don't know it's still a work in
progress you know still a work in
progress uh yeah it's work can find on
my end uh lutra naras is asking what I
think about Donald Trump rescheduling
his trip to the UK to avoid being
embarrassed uh by protests from the
parliament it happened in multiple steps
first I read that Donald Trump would
actually not be invited to speak at
Parliament and then I read that
afterwards the entire thing was canceled
altogether so I don't know if there were
going to be protests at Parliament
because um it seemed like Donald Trump
wasn't going to be speaking but I think
it's absolutely hilarious I mean again a
lot of really crazy stuff is being
normalized uh because every day there's
one or another level of insanity that
we're hearing from Donald Trump but it's
really crazy what is going on and the
relations and the events that that are
having to do with Trump and other world
leaders meeting or Trump traveling or
whatever uh it's absolutely and utterly
insane um I did the story on today's
show and I think that this clip goes
live live at 6:00 unless you remember in
which case you already have access to
all of today's show on video Donald
Trump pretended to understand Japanese
during this joint uh press uh conference
of sorts with Japanese prime minister
Shinzo ABI and it was absolutely and
utterly insane where Trump had no
earpiece and Shinzo ABI is just speaking
Japanese and Trump's looking at him and
nodding and sort of pretending like he
understands Japanese I mean just
absolutely bizarre it goes to the lack
of preparation that we're seeing from
from the Trump team it's completely and
utterly embarrassing and and absolutely
PA pathetic and I've not ever seen
anything like it and it's really
important in this time that we not allow
it to appear normal because none of this
stuff is normal and we can't normalize
it and say hey this is just this is just
what we have we've got to stay on it
that's exactly what we're trying to do
um okay big thank you to Katherine
LaVine who has just signed up at
davidpakman.com
slash membership uh not using the code I
voted 17 although for anybody who wants
a 40% discount off of membership and I
will do live thank yous during the
stream you can use that coupon code and
get 40% off absolutely any any
membership that you want at
davidpakman.com
membership um okay a lot of people
talking to me about Steven Miller they
want want me to talk about Steven Miller
I I actually don't know what the latest
news is about Steven Miller the Trump uh
spokesperson let's see if I check my
Google
News what is it that that people want me
to uh talk
about okay it seems like stepen Miller
said something crazy and uh Joe Scarboro
schooled him in some way okay might be
an interesting story this is not a story
that I was aware of um
hm in the weeks since Trump's disastrous
no but I asked how to legally ban
Muslims so it's not a Muslim ban Muslim
ban 31-year-old adviser Steven Miller is
enjoying
Fame H all right well I'll check it out
but let me put it this way I have
absolutely nothing to say about uh step
Miller right now um okay question will
you investigate and report on new
technical evidence purportedly showing
DNC Insider Warren flood posing as
Russian hacker guer 2.0 I've not heard
about it um but I absolutely will check
it out Richie Mainville sending a super
chat but not including a question or
comment with it just uh sending a Super
Chat very very nice of him um jalmari
Tela wants to know whether Steve Shives
blocked me on Twitter Steve Shives
Twitter let's see did he block me on
Twitter I don't know why he would i'
I've never had any interaction with
Steve
Shives uh no it doesn't appear as though
Steve Shives has uh blocked me on
Twitter for anybody who who is wondering
about that um thank you to Laura muleh
Houser Laura Mouser has just created a
David Pacman show uh membership at David
pacman.com membership using coupon code
I voted 17 and also a thank you to Jay
Bennett who has taking advantage of
coupon code I voted 17 to create a 40%
discounted membership thank you very
very
much um okay the other thing I do want
to mention that we have coming up on the
David Pacman show is a studio tour we're
kind of right in the middle of a
redesign of the David Pacman show
studio um and I don't know if I should
do the studio tour
before and after and show how it's
changed I mean the whole studio is kind
of a mess right now everything that's
off camera is a total mess so I don't
know if it would just be sort of
embarrassing to do the studio tour
before we get everything all uh cleaned
up in there um but what I thought would
be interesting like maybe even tomorrow
I ran it by Pat today is when we're
doing our pre-show prep for the show so
this includes Gathering all of the
videos and um uh writing blog posts that
will be posted to different places like
Huffington Post Etc after the show goes
live maybe show a lot do a live stream
of our morning meeting I think that that
might be interesting but again it's a
little bit chaotic in our studio so I
don't know I don't know if I should
really do that but in any case it's
something I think I'm thinking of and
eventually we are absolutely going to be
uh doing a a studio tour through the
YouTube live format um and if people
have any other ideas the the other thing
I absolutely plan to do is we have the
new David Pacman show coffee Blends
which are available on our website at
David pacman.com gear I'm going to do
some live streams of actually making
coffee which what could possibly be more
interesting than that uh so watch out
for that uh coming up soon and the
coffee is flying out of here I'm
actually going to go back to bluefire
Coffee Roasters they're about 45 minutes
outside of Boston and Patrick Maloney
runs the company really small coffee
roaster and what I like about it is I
was able to go and roast coffee with
Patrick and say this is too dark yeah
this is actually like coffee that I that
I enjoy and um so we said okay these
will be the David Pacman show Blends I
want to go back out there and maybe even
do a stream uh from bluefire Coffee
Roasters which I think would be really
really cool uh Kathy silis has sent a $2
Super Chat thank you although not uh
including any question with it um okay
thank you uh very very much um David
what do you think about doing more book
recommendations and do you have a
Goodreads account yeah I I do have a
good reads account and every once in a
while I will um sort of uh uh update my
Goodreads and I say just would be great
if I could publish that and people could
see what I'm reading and then I just
forget and I don't update it and then I
have to go back and add 10 or 15 or 20
books to it if it's been a few months so
yeah I'll do more book recommendations I
mentioned this last week I think on a
stream I'm reading the book addiction by
design by Natasha da shol and it's about
the way in which both casinos but also
specifically video slot machines and
video poker are designed to be highly
highly addictive and it is fascinating
and I've not contacted Natasha about
this yet but when I'm done with the book
I'm about two-thirds of the way through
it I'm absolutely going to reach out to
her for an interview because it is a
very very good um book and just and it's
interesting sometimes to dig into a
really specific topic and just learn
about it um and uh see what's going on
there okay instant vote there's a user
who's going by the name of Adolf Hitler
who is commenting things like David
cuckman should it should that person be
banned is that someone that I should
just block from the channel uh let me
know um yeah okay uh thank you to new
David Pacman show member Kai Rob who
subscribed using the coupon code I voted
17 thank you to new David Pacman show
member Gloria welnak who subscribed
again using the coupon code I voted 17
and also thank you to Joe Edwards who
just subscribed also using coupon code I
voted 17 and also thank you to Tate
Delle who has sent not a$2 us super chat
but a two Australian dollar uh Super
Chat okay let's see people saying
whether Adolf Hitler should be banned um
yes yes uh we have one no another yes a
yes A yes a no a yes A yes yeah I I
think um I think Adolf Hitler is going
to be banned um why why allow it just
doesn't really make any sense so bye-bye
to Adolf Hitler he knew me only as a
cuck and uh is already gone
um here's a good question uh from got
shul of
orbase okay I I'm sure I butchered that
what historical period am I most
interested in I've sort of dealt with
this before um I am most interested in
prehistory and I've read a it's a a
short history of prehistory I think
that's the name of the book um and it's
it's interesting to me the idea of how
can we piece together what human history
was like before we had writing and this
includes the earliest forms of Hier
hieroglyphics um Etc so I think that
that's most interesting to me just as as
long ago in the um uh existence of
modern humans and of course you know do
we have five8 10,000 years of of some
kind of of more specific Visual History
of sorts if not written pictorial modern
humans been around for about 250,000
years so that that's the the period I'm
super interested in um e AOS AOS I
believe is the username has sent a $5
Super Chat saying glad to see you use my
thumbnail for the show today I'm a big
fan um yes I think that ailos is
referring to the Donald Trump holding a
reading for dummies book I believe that
that's who ailos is uh great work on it
uh really really liked it uh we have
another Super Chat somewhere here from
Ryan Couture who says why wait for
decriminalization over legalization when
you can't oh why for decriminalization
over legalization when you can't tax and
regulate it okay this is a good question
I prefer
legalization um of
marijuana uh and there's other drugs on
the list of drugs where I favor
legalization although though there are
some drugs I've not yet fully formed my
position on this I could be convinced
that there are some drugs that should be
decriminalized but not necessarily
legalized but I I I'm still flexible on
that I'm not totally sure um
decriminalization is easier to achieve
in many cases than
legalization and I think because of that
if legalization is just not a reasonable
option immediately or in in the near
future I think criminalization is a
logical uh in between or a logical way
to go at least with regards to how it
impacts the War on Drugs Etc so yeah I
mean generally I'm a legalization guy
but I don't think there's anything wrong
with pushing for decriminalization if it
seems like like legalization is just
going to be uh difficult um suggestion
that I interview uh Robert R is it r or
Reich I never remember is it Third Reich
and Robert R or vice versa I don't know
but we've tried to get an interview
um with Robert R and he's never
responded I would love to have him on if
anyone is in contact with him by all
means please uh let him know we we would
like to interview him Rebecca starovic
has weighed in
heavily on issue of me block people
are the
by free
to
isn't
absolutely
correct last week
T
HB no
I no I did not very very
good watch
I
user
the the chat
said
that
be was going
be what they
talk
about
which
said we
don't
me
take
that that's
Nots you know we
can't and
then
back the the
Entre even
though
you really good you ignorant bastard I'm
not looking to anger anybody
here I
think
most
people
B
is
really
run
but
this
I
run the
here
still
people
but just not a way to a show it just it
really isn't
um
okay uh
let's
see
what
no
but I I think it's
like
where
m
when
t
in
a
very
okay
dis
get
well
J
dur during
the
okay I I've convinced that I need to
watch the Steven Miller video because a
lot of people are
com
it's
when
yeah
my
no
years
yeah
this
but
don't
people
that
this
is
so
speci
answer
next
we
and
just
order
think
I
will
be